Speaker 1: Hey, this is really, really good.
Our friend Tim Miller, a moderate Republican
who we've interviewed on the program before,
confronted Kerry Lake. Okay. And this is super,
super interesting. This is from Tim's show
on Showtime. He confronted Kerry Lake and he
said something that many moderate Republicans
believe, which is we should get away from this
cartoonish MAGA, Trumpism, which includes people
like Harry, like and we should be going back to
moderate Republicanism if we want to win. How
did Cory Lake respond? Well, she responded by
telling lies and by making fun of the way Tim
was dressed. That's that's what she did. Let's
take a look. Take a listen. Nice job here by Tim.
Speaker 4: Hailey and Fabio. And they're saying
that we've lost three straight elections, that
it's time to change the strategy, maybe appeal
out to more moderate voters. You just
lost the election. Let's say you do that.
Speaker 5: Well, they like to say we lost
elections for having corrupt stolen elections.
Speaker 1: Okay. That's a lie. She lost. It's
very simple. She lost. So she's already lying.
Speaker 5: We're having to corrupt
stolen elections. President Trump
won that election in 2020.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump
did not win in 2020. There was.
Speaker 5: Corruption. I know you
don't believe it and you don't want to look at it.
And they sold the election for me. And you guys.
Speaker 1: Were. She did not have the election
stolen. Her opponent received more votes,
meaning her opponent becomes the governor.
Speaker 4: Don't you think you know,
he lost the election because you didn't reach out
to the McCain voters? You're talking to voters.
Speaker 5: No.
Speaker 4: I you know,
when you campaigned hard maga.
Speaker 5: That's fake news.
Speaker 4: I went to your
last event. It was Stevie.
Speaker 1: She did kind of campaign hard maga.
Speaker 4: It was all because it was hard
maga. You want to go into my people, you
have to go to moderate Republican. Maybe
you too want. If you would have told me.
Speaker 5: May I have a word? Did you want
to do an interview? You seem
to be doing all the talking.
Speaker 4: That's the question.
Speaker 5: It was a year before
the election when I had a financial
nuclear bomb dropped on me by a
McCain Republican.
Speaker 2: A bomb.
Speaker 5: Dropped $30 million in a.
Speaker 1: Massive dump.
Speaker 5: PAC ads. We were joking around. I
said, we have to keep Republicans in here. And I
brought the establishment together. Let me finish
from the establishment together. Unfortunately,
a few of them didn't come over and they she.
Speaker 1: Did not bring the establishment
together. She ran an insanely divisive campaign.
Speaker 5: In the election. I know you don't
believe in you refuse to look at you
refuse to look at the evidence. Okay.
Speaker 4: I do look at the evidence. I
wasn't at your campaign rally. Three days
were Russian. You don't know McCain's there.
None of the Jews, they were welcome there.
Speaker 5: I. I actually tried. I reached out
to do see and I reached out to all of those
people. They didn't want to come around. I can't
help it. But what I do have are independents and
Democrats. How old are you?
Speaker 4: I'm 41.
Speaker 5: 41. And you dress like a 13 year old.
Speaker 4: Oh, Kerry, come on. Seven and a half.
Speaker 1: All right, so that's from the circus
on Showtime, which I encourage you to check out.
So this is interesting because there's
two aspects of this layer. One is,
she continues telling the same lies
that have been debunked endlessly. She
just keeps telling them Trump actually won. I
actually won. I reached out across the aisle,
all these different things. All of those are
lies. But then it's going to add homonyms
when you have no other choice, because Tim
Miller is, of course, completely correct. Now,
the practical and strategic question going into
2024 becomes does that dynamic remain and which
of course will damage the Republican Party
and their chances, or do they realize that
this MAGA Trumpism has actually been quite
damaging? It lost them the house in 2018,
it lost them everything in 2018. It lost them the
presidency, it lost them the Senate. It prevented
a red way from being what it could have been,
all those different things. And do they change
or do they stick with it? That's the question.
Adam Schiff joins me after this short break.